un film est sorti à paris
le vieil homme et l'enfant tout le monde
en parle mais qui est son auteur claude
berri un jeune homme inconnu qui a déjà
remporté un oscar à hollywood
françois chalais vous le présente un
jour les français ont appris avec une
certaine étonnement qu'un français
parfaitement inconnu venait de remporter
à hollywood l'oscar du court métrage
avec un petit film d'ailleurs pas vu
davantage s'appelle le poulet
or ce français claude berri c'était vous
l'idée c'est un fait divers que j'évolue
dans françois
un jour j'ai lu j'ai un jour j'ai acheté
france soir et j'ai lu à la page 3 pour
que vive son coq alain six ans lui
faisait pondre un oeuf par jour alors de
chez lui ses 5 6 lié et de voir qu'un
enfant arrivé à faire pondre un coq sa
malle
ça m'a amusé et j'ai fait le poulet
metteur en scène insolite claude berri
ne l'est pas seulement par le sujet de
ses films mais par ses origines
né d'un père polonais d'une mère
roumaine il a passé toute son enfance
dans un quartier qui n'a que peu de
rapport avec l'avenue foch puisqu'il
s'étend de la rue saint denis à la rue
du faubourg poissonnière où il vit
toujours
oui avant de diriger un étonnant michel
simon dans le vieil homme et l'enfant
claude berri n'a pas connu précisément
pour chemin celui qui conduit tout droit
à hollywood
vous auriez dû être fort normalement oui
mais j'ai été fourrure mais savait fort
bien sûr j'ai fait des pour pas dire des
milliers des centaines de manteau en
queues de vison
non c'est vrai on est là dans un atelier
de fourrure encore ma mère travaille on
prend un peu la fourrure non je j'ai été
folle mais pas ses poils et wafa décidé
mal à cette époque là je pensais pas non
plus à faire de la fourrure
vous voyez faire court et je voulais
rien faire enfin je sais pas qu'est ce
que je voulais faire je courais les
filles je joue aux cartes il fallait
bien faire quelque chose et puis j'avais
mon père depuis tellement d'années
tout petit déjà mon père a toujours
voulu m'associer à ses responsabilités
il avait raison mon père rêvait que je
devienne fourrure avec lui qu'à nous
deux on montrait une grosse a fait on
serait les rois dans la fourrure et les
quinze ans plus tard s'il n'était pas
mort on aurait été les rois dans le film
j'avais quel âge peut béret 32 ans
qu'avez vous coller de l'occupation ce
que je raconte dans mon film je comme
j'ai toujours été un enfant gâté très
heureux malgré malgré la guerre mes
parents ou pauvre où se cache un homme a
toujours préservé j'ai toujours été
préservé ce que j'ai connu l'occupation
s'est gelé vécu mais je l' ai vécu à ma
façon
certains ont été déportés certains on
vous fait de la résistance certains
étaient très heureux moi j'ai plutôt été
heureux d'une certaine façon le vieil
homme et l'enfant c'est votre histoire
finalement oui c'est mon histoire
pouvez-vous évoquer le thème rapidement
eh bien disons que quand j'avais une
neuf ans
début 44 cas ont été cachés près du lion
le danger devenait enfin bon les rafles
était de plus en plus fréquentes à mes
parents paper une histoire de lettres
anonymes enfin de dénonciation les gens
la femme qui cache mes parents fin qui
nous cachait à dick a proposé de mettre
à la campagne chez ses parents la
condition était de mettre sous un faux
nom parce que ses parents étaient un peu
influencé par la propagande de l'époque
étaient des braves gens mais aurait pris
peur à l'idée de savoir que que j'étais
juif
donc pour moi enfant ça m'a amusé de
vivre pendant six mois sous un faux nom
et ces gens écoutent à philippe henriot
écouter les éditoriaux n'est même pas
les juifs et je ne sais même pas enfin
dans mon imagination d'enfants non mais
même d'ailleurs même pas je me rendais
bien compte qu'ils étaient une offensive
sans ça je n'aurais pas fait le film que
j'ai fait c'est à dire que je dis que
c'est mon histoire bien entendu mais
enfin je les jeux les transposer j'ai
vécu pendant six mois sous un faux nom à
la campagne chez des gens qui ne
savaient pas que j'étais juif et je le
faisais tous les jours parler des juifs
parce que ça m'amusait parce que je
savais qu'ils étaient mythifié je savais
que ce qu'ils disent à des juifs étaient
absolument faux et je m'en amuse aime ma
distraction favorite c'était de leur
faire parler des juifs mais le
malentendu dans le dans le monde et dans
la vie c'est que les gens ils sont
toujours ailleurs ils connaissent pas
leur concierge et y parle de je ne sais
pas quoi ils ont des idées surtout ils
feraient mieux de se regarder de parler
d'eux de parler de ce qu'ils ont vu et
surtout jour ailleurs jeudi paillade et
philosophe il faut avoir des idées
générales
mais enfin il ya des tas de gens qui
n'ont pas les moyens de se payer des
idées générales
[Musique]